- Woo hoo!
(howls and trills tongue)
(laughter)
(cadence lypso music)
- Is it pronounced Cuh-rib-ih-yun,
or Care-rib-bee-yun?
- I didn't know jerk chicken
was a part of the Caribbean aspect.
I had some jerk chicken wings--
- Oh so now he wants to
say he had jerk chicken.
- No Buffalo Wild Wings got
some good jerk chicken sauce.
- That is not Caribbean.
- I know this is not accurate,
but I think of tourists
and tiki drinks.
- I am expecting just a
lot of beauty in my mouth,
lot of good stuff in my mouth.
(cadence lypso music)
- [Man in Minuteman shirt]
So it looks like a crepe.
- It's glistening in oil.
- Yeah.
- It looks like a burnt pancake.
(chewing noises)
- I like this one.
- It's not bad, but it's not
that good either. (laughter)
- It tastes bad.
- The more you taste it though...
- The more it kind of gets good.
- It like grows on you.
- Yeah it was like, okay, yeah.
- I guess it is like from
Barbados, like Rihanna.
The more she sings, it's like, yeah okay.
- Yeah, okay, I'll rock with it.
(cadence lypso music)
- It looks like something you'd find
at the bottom of the ocean.
- It looks like chicken pot pie.
- Yes, it also kind of
looks like a pineapple taco.
- Reminds me a little bit of Indian,
just like the consistency.
- Yes, definitely.
- Not going to lie, this
actually blew my mind.
- [Man in Status Quo
shirt] It's pretty good.
(cadence lypso music)
- It smells fried.
- This looks like a doughnut,
and I love doughnuts.
- When I first bit into it,
I had this pastry feeling.
- This would be a good sandwich almost--
- Yeah.
- If you put something in this.
- This is a very dense ball of dough.
- I would eat this, all the time.
- Oh RIhanna looks she would
probably eat something--
- Rihanna looked like
she might make these.
- She likes meaty, whole
round things, I feel like.
(cadence lypso music)
- It's oxtail.
- Oh.
- This looks so delicious to me.
- You can make plate art with it.
- It just kind of looks like a turd.
(pleased humming)
- It has a nice little glaze on it.
- It's sweet, kind of like a pot roast.
- I like how tender it is.
- Oxtail?
(laughter)
- I love this, this is great.
(cadence lypso music)
- It smells Cinnamon-ey.
- Oh, that's not rice, that's coconut.
- That's coconut?!
- Oh, I hate jello.
Is this jello?
- It melts in your mouth.
- It feels like I'm eating a Teletubby.
- Rihanna, this one is not going to do.
Don't pass this out at the concert.
- They have interesting
textural things going on.
- That's very true.
- Everything is delicious, I love it.
I will go and visit you guys
and eat all of your food.
- I would definitely get
back on some of that oxtail,
and the con-fung-blok-tay, (spoken over).
- I'm pretty sure that's
not how you say it.
- We need to go on a
trip to the Caribbean.
- As long as you're paying.
- Cheers. (laughter)
- Shout out to Rihanna, shout
out to all the Caribbeans.
Shout out to Johnny Depp and
the Pirates of the Caribbean.
(upbeat cadence lypso music)